استحواذ ايلون ماسك على تويتر خطوه مهمه
على طريق ضمان حريه التعبير عالميا ولكن
بحسب صحيفه فلسطين جورنال الصحيفه قالت ان
شركات التقنيه الاكبر في العالم اوجدت
انماطا معينه من الخطاب واذا لم يتم
الالتزام بهذه الانماط فسيكون الحظر هو
البديل خلال هذه الفتره حاول تعديد من
المدافعين عن حريه التعبير حاولوا شقه
طريقهم لكنهم تعرضوا للقمع من عمالقه
التكنولوجيا المهيمنه وحاول البعض ايجاد
من السطات بديله مثل بارلر وتروس سوشيال
كبديل عن تويتر ومجددا وجهه وبحضر التطبيق
على متاجر التطبيقات
التعبير خاصه
اكثر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي نشاطا في
العالم فكره ماسك عن عدم وجود قيود على
التعبير قبلت باراء متضاربه بين من اعتبره
انجازا ومن اعتبره يفتح الباب لخطاب
الكراهيه اشارت الصحيفه ايضا الى القيود
التي وضعتها شركات التكنولوجيا على
التعبير خاصه خلال ذروه جائحه كورونا مكان
له تاثير حقيقي على السياسه والطب
والادراك العام للشعوب
موقع تويتر
مثل ما يشاء خاصه وان القوانين الامريكيه
تتيح للشركات الخاصه ان تضع قوانينها
الخاصه
يرمي حجرا في بركه عمالقه التقنيه وقد
يثير نقاشا حقيقيا حول حريات التعبير
اضافه الى انه قد يواصل فتح الفساد
والانتفاخ داخل شركات التكنولوجيا والطرق
التي تستخدمها لكتبت الاصوات المعارضه
لملاك هذه من الصاد وهم في اغلبهم من
اليسار في الولايات المتحده جهود مصر بحسب
وصله مجرد مشروع راس مالي اخر قد يكون
ناجحا او لا من وجهه نظر اقتصاديه لكن من
وجهه نظر اجتماعيه فقد بدا بالفعل بخرق
السقف الذي وضعته وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
[موسيقى]